en el castillo de balmoral los oficiales
hacen guardia mientras la familia real
se apresura para estar al lado de la
reina isabel segunda permanece bajo
supervisión médica en su hogar escocés
después de que los médicos expresaron
preocupación por su salud en westminster
londres el parlamento se tomó un momento
para expresar su apoyo a la monarca en
96 años
anuales sé que hablo el nombre de toda
la cámara cuando digo que enviamos
nuestros mejores deseos a su majestad la
reina y que ella y la familia real están
en nuestros pensamientos y oraciones en
este momento dado antes por la reina
isabel ha sufrido problemas de salud
desde octubre pasado experimentando lo
que sus portavoces han llamado problemas
de movilidad episódica obligándola a
reducir las apariciones públicas
el martes la reina recibió el primer
ministro saliente boris johnson en
balmoral quien presentó su renuncia
antes de que listos asumiera como su
reemplazo al día siguiente canceló una
reunión virtual de su consejo privado
cuando sus médicos le aconsejaron
descansar cross tuiteó su preocupación
cuando la información sobre el estado de
salud de isabel se extendió por todo el
país desde la oposición el líder
laborista keith stammer hizo lo mismo
este año la soberana regente más longeva
de reino unido celebró 70 años en el
trono el príncipe carlos asumirá la
responsabilidad real una vez que su
madre isabel muera